[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
care west and behind me you know who I
have it's the main man back there
Standells XM studios one full scale
Daniel's now I got this before we went
to packs and packs was a huge success
for the iron Lords pod guys we had such
a great time but during these trying
times when I got back everything changed
the world's changed so we had to
reassess so right now while everybody's
at home doing whatever they have to do
to stay healthy I started to clean up
started to change up and started to
bring you better content more dynamic
range more better audio better video so
without further ado
I give you the comic book accurate XM
studio Standells now let me tell you
something I'm a huge Santos fan as you
can tell from the Infinity Gauntlet to
the Danielson throne from sideshow to my
bowing stato huge tennis fan not really
too much a fan of the movie Thanos
because they had to do a little things
to change him to make him fit but if you
may see in his hand and this is how I
will be displaying him I will be
displaying him with the Infinity
Gauntlet and what you guys call the
tesseract or what I call the cosmic you
see early on in Thanos career he was
after the Cosmic Cube which was the
all-powerful weapon then later on he got
that Infinity Gauntlet that made him
omnipotent you see so it's very
important for me to depict it in that
fashion
now XM Studios has a ton of switch outs
with this guy I have three different
switch our heads three different
possible poses a very detailed base very
comic-book accurate colors I love how on
the boots the texturing from the
weathered their toes to the belt to even
the details on his head and his neck
cause this statue is out of control
and I got it for the price that I felt
that I was able to pay for it it goes
for you may catch it somewhere anywhere
from $1,100 to $1,300 I got it for a
really good price from a very good guy
on eBay
and it also came with the limited
edition coin see early on in sideshows
tenure they will also with the art print
that I'm going to show at the end they
would give you a limited edition coin
and a lot of times these guys keep the
coin or they sell a coin for like $200
and you know and you get a statute with
no coin well I got this danos with the
coin and I am absolutely pleased so what
I like for you to do is to go to loads
of gaming dotnet where you can share a
ton of opinion pieces a lot of iron
Lords podcast whole episode also the
last word with Lord kognito Andy bonta's
I mean it gets me tongue-tied sometimes
because let me tell you something these
guys are going in every Friday and
giving you up-to-date facts on the
changes to switch outs and everything
that you need to do when you're playing
destiny destiny to is fantastic also the
division Lew the shooter news at the
last word is second to none please check
it out make sure you go there every
Friday I'm telling you it's a ton of
laughs plus also as a huge amount of
facts you can also catch old episodes of
Kos and loads of gaming dotnet where I
have the Infinity Gauntlet and also
sideshows Thanos on throne so you can
watch that episode as well those two
episodes see you next week when I bring
you something truly amazing and
something
and I think you guys have been asking
for always stay collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]